all right welcome everybody i'm jumping
right on today because it seems as
though the president
whoa okay there's music playing so we
got to keep that down it seems as though
trump may be arriving now although they
might just be putting
this plane in place and he may actually
be coming up via car
i'm not actually totally sure what's
going on but i wanted to make sure we
didn't miss it since i haven't streamed
for a few days
uh it's it's our first day back i am
back in the studio out of the bunker and
into the studio as we see the rolling
staircase approaching
um looks like a 757 uh probably has some
other air force name
uh smaller version whoa what just
happened there
smaller version of trump's uh plane that
he's using
presumably at smaller runways
would be my guess um we do have
uh dnc coverage coming up later today
okay so at 8
40 p.m eastern time we will be starting
potentially four contin continuous days
consecutive days
of um dnc coverage in the evenings now
i'm gonna be totally transparent and
frank here with you i'm not i'm not
gonna gaslight anybody
if the dnc streams don't do well i
probably won't do them every day i mean
i
my sense is there could be big interest
and there also might not be
and i would love to do some great big
powerful streams maybe open the phone
lines and do different things
but if they don't do well listen i mean
i i can go to bed you know i don't need
to be up till after 11
streaming necessarily but we're gonna
try it so at least today it's scheduled
for 11 40 pm eastern time um
after this stream i'm going to go do a
little grilling do a little gardening
maybe clean myself up and then i'll be
back with you guys at 8 40 p.m
eastern time um and people asking
no i'm there is a break there is going
to be a very very
strong and powerful break thanks to eric
dahlin and
tool fandomania for the youtube
subscriptions
alexander the grape says via twitch
subscription
i hope you play chess with your friend
stephen kenneth destiny bennell ii
soon that may be happening of course we
do have this
friday pogchamps 2 starts and that's
going to be
very very exciting people
do i have memes i do have memes today
but i might save them for later i don't
know
i mean it looks like trump might be
coming out very soon
uh i did see this on our subreddit i
just became a member rumor has it this
deal is
illegal in some states how do i make
sure i don't get arrested for it and as
you can see here
they did indeed use the coupon code july
surprise for 66.25
off that's a lot and a lot of people
uh like this woman getting right on the
phone she'll be calling the cop so
you've got to be very careful with that
um so there's one thing that was sent to
me i do also have videos of people's
pets watching the david pakman show i
asked for some of those
but i don't want to rush through that
stuff so
if trump's about to speak i'm going to
wait and then maybe we'll do those later
maybe we'll even do them during the dnc
stream i have you know i build up all
this content over the weekend
i don't want to just disparage it
very quickly chakuseki says via super
chat
trump's minnesota speech opened with him
saying we need to take back the white
house
is he confused or is the plasma adderall
finally kicking in
i didn't see that clip but that sounds
very weird
um we do have a video going gigaviral
that just was published an hour ago
it already has 105 000 views it's about
trump's bizarre press briefing over the
weekend
with supporters cheering it's like guys
what are you cheering
this is this is crazy what what on earth
would you possibly be cheering
um that's on my youtube channel right
now
and one very exciting bit of data
is that we are now we have you
have so powerfully hit the subscribe
button on my youtube channel
that we now are only one day off from
being on track to hit a million
subscribers on election day
election day is november 3rd right or is
it the fourth no it's the third
election day is november 3rd we are
currently projected to hit 1
million youtube subscribers on the 4th
so if we can keep it up
we will soon pull that to election day
or even closer which is just
unbelievable and in fact danny thompson
sends a super chat about
that saying woo hoo almost 950
000 very powerful subscribers please
update the expected day oh okay
uh i read your mind i read your mind
danny just updated it we are now
targeting
november 4th and maybe looking at
november 3rd
very very soon um twitch things are
going beautifully on twitch as well
we are close to 45 000 followers and of
course 50 000 is the immediate target
uh and that's going to be great dylan
artunian
asks david are you a backpack or a
satchel guy
well i have a herschel backpack that i
travel with
but typically if i'm just out at a cafe
with my laptop
um i almost have like just a laptop
sleeve it doesn't even have an over the
shoulder thing i just carry it
um like a book under my arm so you
should see it's wild
bay photo asks what's up with the new
polls i will discuss that on tomorrow's
show so i don't want to get ahead of
that a user named
cam which might be short for cameron or
whatever cameron something hulto
okay not an idiot there is talk on
social media about starting a change.org
petition to get you to refund
those who send super chats that are not
read on air
yeah there you go um i don't there's not
even a function to refund a super chat
and listen i mean i try to get to
um as many super chats as i can but the
risk when you send a super chat is i
won't get to it now this is the time to
send them because once things get going
and things start accelerating that's
when it's hard to get to the super chat
so this is the time to do it
for example jacob parise says hello
gorgeous
amy gray says will you be doing a live
stream on election night
listen i'm gonna be doing a live stream
tonight for the dnc
and if it goes well i'll do one tomorrow
night for the dnc
election day is you're thinking further
ahead than i am
let me say a huge thank you to
kurt stewmeeds i hope i'm pronouncing
that correctly
stummits who is new member number one at
jointpakman.com
as well as mj tuck who is new member
number two today
at joinpackman.com i have a new system
powerful system for marking the people
whose names i read
so i'm not going to miss anybody anymore
so for example
michael raleigh is new member number
three today and now
michael has been marked off as the term
may be
and now we know that i got
uh i got uh that that taken care of and
it is going
really really well um what else do i
have
here uh okay we did that already we did
a million subscribers already
let me show you a couple of other things
as we wait here
here are there's a couple million
million subscriber related memes
this one seems a little a little
pejorative to sam cedar
race to one million loser says what
sam says what whoa and then uh
you know i'm on the bottom there that i
don't know about that one this one i
like
sam claiming hold on a second let me see
if i can get this
let me zoom this out oh boy this is not
going well hold on a second oh i am
zoomed out all the way this is crazy ah
there we go
hold on there we go that's beautiful
um he's using bots
look at the chart jonathan swann very
very confused wait are we missing trump
no we're not just making sure we're not
missing trump
so i like this one this one's pretty
good um
oh here's a video of uh this is
bernie the french bulldog watching
the david pakman show i think you'll
like this let's see
and he wants it done by a federal decree
this would lead to a crippling long wall
uh it looks like he's actually watching
trump not me
lasting depression long-lasting
depression and yesterday i showed you
the numbers about how well we're doing
coming back with what i'm saying
he's so studious manufacturing and used
car sales and housing
focused in though that is interesting
nobody would have believed and we're
back and very strong it's a very strong
v
it's so much news okay so there's that
one
uh oh tdps bingo here's another meme
commander do you know what this means
absolutely nothing everyone needs to get
out and vote in november
okay and then here is this is
ruby the cat this is ruby the cat
watching the david pakman show right so
i believe this dog is named willow
if you
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right well hey to ruby very much
appreciate it and then still waiting on
trump
uh here is kent lovelace my face when
david pakman
offers a ludicrous and possibly illegal
membership deal
well said very very much well said so
from the standpoint of memes that's all
that i have today
if you have any to send me you can use
our website contact form davidpakman.com
uh pets watching the david pakman show
score very highly
and will almost certainly almost
certainly be um
on a future live stream david ebert
is new member number four today now to
be totally transparent david made a
patreon pledge
but we're counting everything it's
members and patrons both of them count
and also thanks to mr potato bug for
subscribing with twitch
prime um robert fancy pants motorcycle
mcgee
says this super chat won't even get you
a coffee but it will make you happy
it's 50 argentinian pesos which i think
now it's trading at 120 a dollar
so that's like 70 cents right that's not
good it's not good what's happening with
the currency in my home country
really really bad christopher mizel
says greetings from austria central
europe yeah i know where austria is
thank you though zachary lancaster says
david what do you think of the new uap
task force i don't know enough about it
to comment yet
uh thanks to nato jenkins tv for gifting
five subscriptions on twitch
dive down 25 asks where will you put the
one million
subscriber plaque from youtube i don't
know
the hundred thousand this is sad but the
hundred thousand subscriber plaque
is propped up against the wall near the
door to my studio
behind a poster
man it's true though it's true mr
d madness says do you think the military
will remove him on november 3rd
well no november 3rd is november 3rd is
election day
he would still be president until
january 20th here is donald trump coming
out as the case may be
let's see if we have a white house feed
um not seeing a white house feed so
let's see if there's music
yeah so we've got to keep it down until
the um
the music pipes down because otherwise
it could cause a problem
as far as copyright is concerned and we
certainly don't want that
how did i survive the metoo movement
unlike my peers
beautiful question beautiful question
probably for another day
let's see if we've still got music yeah
i'm just going to wait until trump
actually comes to the podium
because i don't want to accidentally get
into copyright trouble
i will invite you in this key moment
we are mostly funded by memberships on
our website
so support the work we do we will be
potentially streaming every night this
week for the dnc
certainly tonight at 8 40. we do the
podcast we do the youtube channel the
interviews everything it's mostly funded
by people
who say i like david or maybe you don't
like me but you think the work i'm doing
is valuable
you go to joinpacman.com and you grab a
membership there's a coupon code there
for 66
off i invite you to do it four people
already have
and uh once donald trump is done
speaking
i will make sure to uh thank everybody
who signs up
as we wait here for donald trump
um la laker says hey david do you see a
situation where trump gets so desperate
he replaces pence on the ticket i don't
think so
i don't think so we have a hype train
leaving the station as donald trump's
belligerence has left
the plane behind him uh albi1
play has subscribed with prime and
donald trump uh
clapping i guess for himself let's see
if music is still going
yep it's still going i think playing a
split second like that won't trigger a
copyright issue for me
but anymore potentially will so i'm
going to be very very careful with that
donald trump's teleprompter which he
criticized barack obama for using is in
place
and we are essentially ready to go
wow wow i don't know what happened
something happened this is supposed to
be just a
quick little small gathering this is
what's happening
and we call it a peaceful protest that
way you can
oh god you know we're supposed to have
50 people right
so we have a little more and they turned
away a lot of people outside
so we'll call it a peaceful protest that
way we can do whatever we want
wait till the pictures are released and
there's like no one there you know
that's what they call it
in new york in these different places
portland
when they're rioting all over the
streets they say it was a peaceful
protest so you can have thousands of
people doing it
we'll do the same thing i'm truly
thrilled to be here with you
the hard-working patriots of wisconsin
thank you
thank you it's a big group of people oh
god
this is like a rally it's not supposed
to be a rally we're not supposed to go
around
well i hereby grant you a pardon
[Music]
thank you thank you very much
anybody else nauseous well i want to
thank you thank you
in the months ahead we will need every
ounce of your strength and drive and
patriotism
we're in a fight for the survival of our
nation and civilization itself
moving him depends on it this is the
most
important election we've ever had in my
opinion that may be true i used to say
it and i'd say it with
great conviction that may be true 2016
but you know what
that wasn't crazy people we were dealing
they were right
you know on the on the edge now we're
really dealing with crazy people 60
million of them who plan to vote for
this guy
came crazy later on when she lost that's
what she became
but these are people that are seriously
radical left
joe biden is nothing but their puppet he
has no clue what's happening
i wish joe biden was radical left and
they're making speeches that are taped
who wants to listen to michelle
obama do a tape speech no
you got to have her get up there but
we're doing a real speech on thursday
next thursday she'll be listening
doing it live live from the white house
live from the white house so we have we
have plenty to say
so joe biden and the democrats have
pledged to impose
four trillion dollars of new taxes so
this is a
a group of people they're opposing new
taxes
that sounds good right why would he be
against that a politician would lower
taxes right
the great scott walker is here your
governor oh my god
vile guy and scott would lower taxes but
now the whole thing i guess it's changed
by the way scott walker is not currently
the governor that's weird
republicans are lowering your taxes we
gave you the biggest
tax decrease in the history of our
country and we're going lower
but they're going to massively you guys
think trump thinks walker is
still the governor of wisconsin that was
weird confiscate the guns of law-abiding
americans they're going to take away
your second amendment
they're going to make america a
sanctuary for criminal aliens they're
going to keep those sanctuary cities
they love sanctuary cities
they're going to protect the criminals
abolish american energy and make us
reliant on foreign nations and force
taxpayers to fund extreme
late term abortion that's what they're
doing
that none of that is true of course i'm
sure you know that
by allowing far left washington
bureaucrats to force the construction of
low-income housing projects in every
neighborhood
in america that's what they want to do
that's their goal
and we're going to let you preserve your
american dream in the suburbs okay
we ended the program dog whistle we
ended the program
the voters of wisconsin are very very
spectacular people
we are going to take care of you at
every level we are going to fight for
you
we are going to fight for every single
aspect that you have going
we are never going to forget you you
didn't forget me in the last election
so i want to thank you very much
weird speech strange energy
thank you everybody thank you i want to
thank you very much
it's great so we issued a regulation
and you know we ended that regulation
because when we talk about suburbs and
we talk about other ways they issued it
and ended it why not just not do it
of obama regulations
executive orders you know it's amazing
we knocked out a big portion of what he
did including the uh
wonderful mandate right the individual
mandated obamacare which
totally by the way by far the worst of
all of obamacare
we took it out essentially that ended
obamacare
not true and then you say
so we knocked out 84 percent of what he
did they say he was a wonderful
president why was he a wonderful
president
if we knocked out and a very popular way
knocked out 84 percent the voters of
wisconsin face a simple choice
do you want to be rule
want to stand tall as free men and women
in the greatest country on earth and
keep it that way
is he reading this or is he off script
because maybe somebody can't write
policies of sleepy joe biden
and his boss kamala harris kamala
still can't say it huh and his other
boss
nancy pelosi she's a beauty will he get
the kamala correct by the end do you
think
and his ruler bernie sanders crazy
barney
the real guy in charge is the old jew
that's interesting
in the history of the world which we did
we're gonna have to do it again
we're gonna have to do it again and
we're in the process of doing it
we built the greatest economy on earth
and now we're doing it again you look at
all the numbers we're going to go over
them
do you want to defund and defame and
dismantle the police i don't think so
do you want to support the incredible
heroes of law enforcement yes right
[Applause]
do you want your friends and family to
be persecuted by the far left wing
it's called cancel culture right
cancel culture right or do you want to
defend our history
our heroes our faith our values trump
should really familiarize himself with
the speech before he shows up and looks
at it on the prompter he might be able
to deliver it a more in a more logical
way
now don't believe the lies you're going
to hear on tape
most is going to be i wonder is joe
biden taping his speech too because
if he is i think i'll tape mine
okay how do you watch it taped they talk
about a convention how do you watch a
tape speech
i would imagine joe is going to do
everything he can to tape it
i saw them asking him questions today it
was a news conference then he read them
off a teleprompter i don't get it
i don't get it something going on up
there he's he's he's manic actually he
seems hypomanic
you know i can tell you this look from
doing this now
we built the greatest economy in the
world we rebuilt our military we gave
you the greatest tax cuts in history
gave you the greatest regulation cuts
we became energy independent it's weird
because like
he lies about this stuff in ways that
most politicians don't but then there's
never any follow-up nobody's asked you
know
here in the history of your state last
year greatest year
and when you look at the numbers you're
going to have an even greater year next
year unless somebody comes in and
quadruples your taxes
in which case it's called the depression
folks it's called a depression
it's not going to happen because we're
going to win
biden is just a trojan horse for
socialism
now there is he's a trojan horse i
actually have an interesting clip on
today's show about
is trump actually the most socialistic
president we've had i encourage you to
check it out when we publish it
like her by the way nobody treated
joe biden worse than kamala right
kamala she was worse than pocahontas she
was worse than anybody on stage
nobody treated him worse or with i mean
less respect
she had no respect all of a sudden she's
now saying isn't he wonderful
she didn't feel that way a little while
ago let's talk about her first second
she left in shame she started at 14 she
left it too she went in the wrong
direction
well yeah eventually everybody drops out
because the support that's the way a
primary works
what we want speaking of polls fake news
cnn they probably have their camera
going thank you very much
no no no we have to frankly their
pollsters much better than fox because
fox has never gotten it right fox
pollster i don't know who he is but he
hasn't had a clue for about seven here
we go
let me just let me just tell you that
cnn
gave us an increase of 10 or 11 points
in just a short period of time
that we went up and now they call it
margin of error don't believe it
we're way beyond the margin of error
don't believe it
so he's plus four there's a 3.7 margin
of error so it means either
you know biden could be winning by as
much as 11 or trump could be winning by
three that's
that's the way it works nothing special
we went to
great states and every roadway
and highway we had thousands tens of
thousands
i would say at least on each one a
hundred thousand people
from the plane because you know that's
why this isn't a rally
this is again deadly protest we we're
not allowed to do rallies right
because of rules and regulations which
we want to adhere to
but from the plane to an oil well from
the plane to getting law enforcement all
of the sheriffs in florida gave us their
full endorsement all right
i don't know that he's saying anything
that's true it also it all sounds made
up
whirlpool they were out of business they
were going out of business and now
they're a thriving company
because they were dumping washing
machines and dryers into our country and
i stopped it
and i said you want to do that we're
putting a massive tariff
and all of a sudden whirlpool and
thousands of people they work in ohio
and other places it became a really
terrific
company again and we went there
but if you look if you look at the kind
of enthusiasm we have
we have never had the enthusiasm that we
have right now and that includes 2016.
okay well we'll see
and i hate to say it and i don't want to
be rude because i would never be rude
but let me just tell you
joe biden has no enthusiasm
okay no enthusiasm and you don't win
without enthusiasm
like people aren't saying we got to get
him in the only reason they want him in
is they want to stop our great agenda
that's the only reason
that's the only thing he is going and
nobody wins
when you're not on the side of
enthusiasm so we have more
than we ever had in 2016 and in 2016
nobody has ever seen a campaign with
that kind of enthusiasm and we have much
more now
remember he lost the popular vote by
three million
will not stop until they've ransacked
america
and laid waste to our cities your eyes
don't lie
look at portland it's been turned into a
war zone and we want to go in and solve
it we saved the courthouse you believe
it
this can't be good for our health right
security they were great they easily
saved it
after it was pounded portland was
supposed to be watching it but they
weren't so we sent him in
and we will send in the national guard
just like we did
in minnesota you saw what happened there
minneapolis
the national guard went in within 15
minutes the whole thing was over
you should have called him in a week
earlier oh man this guy
my beautiful beautiful fifth avenue in
new york has been looted and pillaged
it was allowed to happen by an
incompetent mayor that doesn't have a
clue
look at what's happened to our diamond
new york was a diamond for the country
look how far it's gone down in chicago
the mayor literally raised up the
drawbridges to prevent hordes of rioters
from
ransacking the city can you believe it
no can you believe it
17 officers were injured in chicago
they had a week a little while ago
during a weekend spree where 78 people
were shot
and 18 died that's worse than
afghanistan which we're getting out of
that's worse than iraq which we're
almost out of that's
worse than syria which we're out of
except we kept the oil but that's okay
we'll have to talk about that
sounds illegal
but this is the future that joe biden
plans to bring
to every city town funny how he's like
look at all of these things that are
terrible while i'm president
that's why you shouldn't vote for joe
biden
i made the
[Applause]
well you know in one speech recently
i called you suburban housewives and
they all loved it
but what i got they said sir i don't
know if that's politically correct i
said don't worry about it they'll get
over it sir routine
but we saved we saved the suburbs the
suburbs and you know what i'm talking
about
and they said about the rule it's a rule
very strong it's like a law
they said sir we can amend it i said i
don't want it amended all that this
is is a just a guideline that said
if you want to receive public funds you
have to just
look at whether there are unfair impacts
along racial or other lines for housing
like that that's all it was he's saying
it's some powerful law that was ruining
the suburbs
he's running our country it will not be
him it will not be him running our
country
they will turn every city into a
portland and they wouldn't mind no one
will be safe
in a biden-run america but while i'm
president
the united states will use every tool
and we've done it
by the way our country is doing great we
have the pandemic should have never been
allowed
should have never been allowed to happen
by china
should have never been allowed to happen
they released it they didn't release it
in china but it came to the united
states and europe 188 all over the world
188 countries all over the world we're
not going to forget it
we're not going to forget it but we're
doing great coming back we're coming
back and our numbers are better than
almost all countries i will tell you
that despite what you hear look at all
of them up there
scott look at all of that fake news it's
unbelievable
unfortunately fox has become fake news
too i don't know what happens to these
people right
wow do you agree box now is fake at
least the other side you know where
they're coming from
but i'll use every tool at my disposal
to arrest those violators of federal law
and put them behind bars and that's what
we're doing
you know when they were ripping down the
statues our great statues they were
ripping them down
i passed and signed something that's
beautiful it says 10 years in prison if
you knocked out a statue there you go
seems reasonable right what happened
scott
i don't see it anymore now they go up
they look at a statue and they say i
don't know
ten years is a long time they say let's
get out of here
but did you notice that three months ago
i signed it they were going to have
thousands of people march on washington
to rip down statues
and these people are sick they're
anarchists they were going to knock down
thomas jefferson george washington
abraham lincoln he was fair game
abraham lincoln so i said these people
are sick they are troubled individuals
they're anarchists and agitators they're
not just protesters
they call them peaceful protesters
you're peaceful protesters on the record
you're peaceful protest anarchists
and by the way you're a lot look at this
guy over here look at the size of that
guy
you're a lot tougher than they are just
so you understand that
right look at the size of that guy trump
identifies large man in audience
but biden and harris are pro-crime
and anti-cop that's there's no other way
to say it and we're anti-crime
we are pro-cop all the way i've gotten
the endorsement
i got the endorsement pat lynch new york
city police they gave us an endorsement
first time
i think he said i think it's the first
time they've ever done it
that means it's been a long time they
don't do that kind of thing they endorse
me
all the sheriffs in florida endorse me
what you have all of the law enforcement
in texas endorse me
we're getting endorsement from we
haven't found anybody that won't endorse
in law enforcement that's not true we
haven't found anybody
and if we do i think they'd probably be
in big trouble i really do
i think they'd be in big trouble because
nobody could figure it out we are
getting the endorsement
of law and these are great people these
are great americans
these are people that want our people to
be safe
okay so we're thrilled today to be
joined by
county sheriffs from across the state
and i'm deeply
honored to receive the endorsement of
more than three dozen wisconsin sheriffs
where are you
they're not there they don't exist
wow
thank you fellas they're good-looking
people
thank you thank you
thank you i like that mask magga
magnum i wonder if he supports trump
he's got magga this big i wonder if he's
a trump
hey thank you sheriff so we appreciate
it good-looking guys
good-looking guys imagine if they
weren't good-looking you know that would
be horrible right
and i'll never let you down sheriffs
i'll never let you down you know that
you know we gave you all of the surplus
equipment we had millions and millions
of dollars
yeah trump's the populist he has all the
big corporations and law enforcement on
his side
they thought it looked too militaristic
meaning it was a lot of it was uh really
defensive equipment so that
we can keep our law enforcement safe and
i distributed it all of hundreds of
millions of dollars
it was sitting there drawing dust and
warehouses that we were probably paying
a fortune for all over the country and
you got it we all got it everybody got
it and everybody's happy
[Music]
as president and as your president i
will always stand with law enforcement
and
that's something that i can't even
imagine anybody saying anything
differently
but this other side does they say it
differently i mean
nobody can even understand it this
november the voters
of wisconsin will not surrender their
beloved state to the left-wing mob and
that's what we're doing
trump calling fox fake news is
interesting like will fox just turn on
trump now i mean what why not
stop the radical left we're going to win
the state of wisconsin
and we are going to win four more years
[Music]
okay
and then after that we'll go for another
four years because
you know what they spy to my campaign we
should get a redo of four years wow
that's authoritarian we caught him
spying it
can you believe it did you see the fbi
agent
he agreed he was pleading that he forged
documents oh that's that's good no no
wait do you see it's going to be
incredible but they spidered my campaign
they spied on our campaign nobody has
ever seen anything like it
you can call it whatever you want i use
the word treason there it is
they got caught they got caught the same
people
doing speeches on tape tonight they
would be gold is
on the way out interviewing people and
being like hey i noticed you clapped
when trump talked about being spied on
and how there was treason
can you explain exactly what happened
what was it that happened there
[Music]
and jim sensenbrenner is around here
someplace
thank you jim thanks jim these guys are
warriors
also a woman who did so great she was so
great in
michigan she headed up michigan and a
republican hadn't won michigan in many
many years
and we got a lot of car companies
building right now in michigan don't we
ronna mcdaniel
ronna mcdaniel we won michigan
is that the one related to romney or
something i said get me the woman that
kept calling me in michigan you have to
come one more time sir i said this is it
then i'd leave and she'd call the next
day one more time
but you know she did a great job thank
you very much ron is fantastic
head of the rnc
and the head of the wisconsin republican
party chairman
andrew hitt andrew this is sad in a lot
of ways how are we doing andrew looking
good
uh beautiful kids andrew good good i'm
gonna blame you andrew if they don't do
it
okay i'll fire you so fast then
andrew's done a great job thank you i
think we are looking great here
you know uh we won it last time and you
remember what a big shockwave because
the republican had
wanted for a long time and they were
waiting for pennsylvania and we won
pennsylvania
if we had lost every vote we would have
won but they didn't want to call it it
got later and later or later than
wisconsin came in and then michigan came
in and then pennsylvania came in
by that time we already had north
carolina
you know it's hard for republicans you
have to run the whole board
because they start off now we're going
to play for new york with all of the
crime in new york i'm going to play for
new york
because we did well in new york well
that that's a bet i would take
even odds on if i was a betting man for
new york we're going to play
i don't know yes we'll do a little bit
of a tiny shot maybe in california they
like me
he could lose by 5 million in california
couldn't he illinois the other one we're
going to do we're going to go after new
jersey we're going to go after virginia
we have a crazy governor of virginia
he doesn't want you to have guns and he
doesn't mind not only abortion
he doesn't mind execution because after
birth
will decide what to do with the baby
right
no no after did you hear this guy first
time i had heard of it scott
after birth we will decide and we will
discuss with the mother
and that's the first time i've heard of
it this is the guy that likes to pretend
he's michael jackson right with the
dancing
his wife saved him great hell is he
talking about another great friend of
mine a great
great politician but really is much more
than a politician
he's an exceptional human being he is
tough
i had to go against him in those
presidential primaries and i want to
tell you there's nobody tougher
but he basically loves his state i mean
he loves his state
and he should be your governor right now
he should be but
okay
he's an exceptional man scott walker
governor scotland
one of the biggest anti-democracy forces
that wisconsin
has maybe ever seen i'll tell you one
thing he's one of the most respected men
he goes into washington everybody stands
up
i really do respect him a lot and uh
imagine standing up because scott walker
walks in the room please don't put
marijuana on the ballot at the same time
you're running
you brought out like a million people
that nobody ever knew coming out right
because there was no way but you could
do whatever you want you know that
you're going to be successful what
whatever you want to do thank you very
much god for being
so before the virus came in from china
unemployment in wisconsin had reached
the lowest rate
ever recorded ever recorded
that was part of scott's thing too i
have to give him a little credit there
right
i have to do that but we created sure
thousand wisconsin manufacturing jobs
everybody said that would be impossible
121 000 wisconsinites
were lifted out of poverty and 100
000 were lifted off of food stamps
because they had good jobs
another way you got people off food
stamps was by kicking them off
economy in the history of the world our
national economy
was better than any economy that had
ever happened before it
and china was having the worst year they
had
in 67 years not that i want that but we
took in billions of dollars we nobody
ever charged china for doing anything
what the money they took out of our
country for so many years
and the presidents that preceded me
should be ashamed of themselves
for allowing it to happen and that
includes sleepy joe is part of that team
this is actually people who are saying
in the chat this is insufferable and
this is the worst they've ever seen
everything is lies you're all right i
mean you're every
every single one of you is correct this
is i've never seen one this bad
but you see today you could multiply it
times 10 or 15 or maybe even 20.
it would have been a horrible it would
not have been sustainable
and now we're bringing it back and we're
bringing it back so strongly
i took unprecedented action to save the
u.s
economy and support wisconsin families
under our paycheck protection program we
helped save over one
million wisconsin jobs earlier this
month
i issued a directive granting emergency
payroll tax relief to every worker
making under one hundred thousand
dollars per year
and this temporary relief will help tens
of millions of american workers and it's
something that people
really i'll tell you the great economist
that's what they wanted the payroll tax
cut
more than any other thing and it really
applies number one they open their
businesses great for them
but really great for you nobody opened
their business because of the payroll
tax cut this this is just wild
november we will forgive these payments
in full if you re-elect him otherwise
you owe that when you file your taxes by
april 15th
nation's policies we're now witnessing
the fastest econo
and and you've seen this right the
fastest economic
recovery in the history of our country
over the past
three months we have already gained much
more
than 9 million jobs nationwide that's a
record
that's not even close by the way
and you know you heard about the v the v
the famous v and they say well maybe not
a v it's got to be an m
it's got to be an s it's got to be they
have no clue
it's turned out to be a super v because
the numbers are much better when you see
the numbers coming
retail spending gdp down 35 is part of
that v
an all-time high and auto production has
surged
28 percent
and in leaving the great plain right
behind me and we have a lot of
televisions we have televisions and
closets i was saying to another group
we have televisions on floors and
ceilings we have tele you can't escape
it if you want to get away from trump
you can't be in that plane because
the fake news and trump you know they're
going to go out of business when i do
leave
right in let's say 16 20 years something
like that
so when we live
when we leave they're all out of
business it's funny huh
i wouldn't say that sleepy joe would be
very exciting to cover i don't think a
lot of let's turn on the television
let's watch what biden's saying today
darling
but you know i just noticed on
television that nasdaq
that's a big deal nasdaq hit an all-time
record today the highest
the highest price ever and the others
are right behind it i mean who would
think we have a pandemic i think we're
way on the other side of the pandemic
we're doing great with vaccines and
therapeutics 7 000 people died in the
last six days
but who would think that we hit a record
with nasdaq and the others are right
there if you would have said we're at
28 000 on the dow or just about and if
you would have said nasdaq hit a new
record high
that's great for your 401ks
look you get the wrong person in here
your 401ks wave goodbye to them they'll
be worthless
they'll be worthless right 401ks that's
one of the things a lot of people are
bragging you know
about four months ago they were very
depressed i said don't sell don't sell
don't worry about don't sell
forget about this and most people held
and they're very
very good but husbands come up to me and
wives come up to me and
one wife was saying sir i always thought
my husband was a financial loser a total
loser he was his big good-looking
policeman and she said you know he's
never been good with money
but over the years over the last few
years i think he was up
89 i said that's not as good as most
people
he said no no my husband is a financial
genius and this good-looking policeman
looked at me and said thank you sir
because i was abused for a long time
about 175
000 coronavirus deaths what is it
and your 401ks are great and your stocks
are great
you know when you see these big
companies going up that's everybody
that's everybody the stock market that's
everybody that's just an indication
and they're smart people they know where
it's going you know they have an
instinct that's better than most people
and they see what's happening
now with all of that we have a headwind
and the headwind is if for any reason
we didn't win that stock market is going
to go down
like a rock goes through remember that
you can go back to the beginning
of the stock market stocks do better
under democratic presidents than
republicans
if that's the indicator you care to look
at even higher so
on election night expect your 401ks and
your socks to go very very high
and i do believe we're going to have a
tremendous success
i do believe
again the most enthusiasm that anybody
has ever seen
in any election is this one the most
enthusiasm
so we gotta get it to vote for who with
your balance be careful
be careful your absentee ballot's great
you're others you've got to be very
careful or go to vote
just go to vote you know
go to vote we have a little problem here
you have a democrat governor who is uh
will do anything
anything to turn things around
[Music]
how's tom tiffany doing by the way
another win we just had a nice win right
is tom tom is around here someplace tom
tiffany just had a great win
we're winning a lot we've won a lot of
house seats we're going to definitely
we're going to take back the house
unlikely very unlikely hard to imagine
as part of our great rebuilding the us
military we also
signed a 5.5 billion
contract anybody good at reading lips
what is his hair
saying right now supporting thousands of
jobs across the street
we've totally rebuilt our military we've
spent 2.5 trillion dollars
all made in the usa all made in the usa
not something to brag about we have new
fighter jets we have new rockets we've
upgraded our nuclear hope to god we
never have to use it
but nobody's even close it was getting
very tired
getting very tired what we've done with
our military is incredible with tanks
speaking of tanks we left our great tank
i was supposed to close down we have a
tank
factory in lima lima ohio
and it was scheduled to close and i went
to see it i said no way we're closing it
because there's no way
we could ever reproduce that incredible
and and
you know what happened we didn't close
it and we are building tanks like you
wouldn't believe
but what we've done with our military
has been incredible and biden
has promised to slash our defense budget
destroying critical jobs but more
importantly
if we don't have defense everything we
talk about is meaningless we have to
have defense
defense of our country especially when
you look at what's happening
outside of our borders so we have the
greatest right now
when i took it over was totally depleted
it was gone
right now we have the greatest military
we've ever had the greatest equipment by
far
we've ever had
[Applause]
now remember the equipment was fine when
trump came in
obama didn't leave the cupboards bearer
everything was fine there was no reason
to start going crazy spending money on
the military
permanently for no scientific reason
biden wants to inflict dramatic
harm on millions of americans with his
basement
strategy locking everyone in their homes
you look at what's happening with some
of and you've got a dose of it right
here i hate to say
with some of these democrat governors
they just don't want to open it up
by the way on november 4th they'll
announce well we've decided
to open november 4th definitely not you
got to get out to those polls
i'm serious this is the most dangerous
election we've ever had the most
dangerous we know because i don't think
we could ever bring it back if they get
in i don't think there's anything called
a comeback
it'll be another venezuela i used to say
that lightly
i now say it very strongly center left
biden is now hugo chavez
it will be a large scale very
large-scale
venezuela if they win
we're going to win my administration by
contrast
is following the science applying common
sense mitigation
sheltering ver you know this we got a
shelter we got to take care but what do
we really have to do
we have to take care of our elderly
people right
our elderly people with heart problems
with
diabetes and we're launching operation
warp speed to deliver effective
treatments
didn't he launch it four months ago
therapeutics
more than 270 therapies are in clinical
trials can you believe it 270
and you're going to be hearing some very
good news very very soon
he's been saying that for months that i
know right
so i'm watching it very closely i don't
need to have them
announced on november 4th ladies and
gentlemen we've found the vaccine it's
perfect i don't need that
i don't need that and hopefully
everyone's looking to do the right thing
we want to get it out
quickly but we're very close so is is
trump implying there might be someone
who could do the vaccine
sooner but they're going to wait until
november 4th for political reasons is
that what trump is asserting here
have reduced the fatality rate in adults
by 85 since april think of that
think of that three vaccines are in the
final stage of clinical trials
and we're mass producing doses already
of that vaccine because we think it
works
and we're going to have it out very
quickly we will defeat the china virus
we will have the greatest economy that
we've ever had
next year unless somebody wants to
quadruple your taxes and the crazy
things that they're talking about
right we will have next how you
quadruple 35
i don't know that means people owe 40
when they work it's crazy
so biden's been there for 47 years
and he's personally supported every
globalist sellout
of the last half century uh-oh globalist
earlier he said bernie the jewish guy is
actually in charge now he goes globalism
world trade organization a total
catastrophe
for korea the korean deal was horrible
we renegotiated it
now it's a really great deal for us one
in four u.s
manufacturing jobs disappeared almost
overnight biden was strongly in favor of
the trans-pacific partnership would have
destroyed our automobile
manufacturing business it would have
been a disaster for our country i
ended it but i approved the dakota
access pipeline immediately
the keystone pipeline 48 000 jobs
he also tried to rehab coal i mean
basically saying let's bring back
every old dirty type of energy that we
can hurt our country because we have so
much energy
we're now energy independent was i got
out of this horrible paris climate
accord
which was a ripoff on our country
embarrassing
global laughing stock it would have
shipped
millions of american jobs to china while
allowing china to pollute with impunity
and they don't even enter the agreement
until 2030
so we it would have been a disaster so
many things are stacked against us
even in the world trade organization
china
is considered a developing nation
therefore they get tremendous guess what
we don't accept it we've informed that
we don't accept it and we're not
we're not approved clueless audience
judges until such time
as that ends
so time and again sleepy joe biden put
china first an american last even to a
point where his son
who had absolutely where's hunter has
anyone seen he's had absolutely no
experience
walked away with one and a half billion
dollars to manage that's millions of
dollars a year
and if you go to the pros of wall street
they'll tell you it's an impossibility
it was a ten minute meeting he walked
away with one and a half billion from
china
how do you think he's gonna do
negotiating biden against china
okay nobody's done what i've done to
china
to russia by the way remember we were
going to be
in a war what exactly did he do to
russia anyway
we're getting along kim jong-un we get
along let's see what happens
in the meantime it's almost four years
right remember we were going to be in a
war
look at look at all those people back
that's a lot of people
that's a lot of people look at all the
fake news isn't that incredible
there are a lot of it's a lot of fake
news back there scott
at the end of joe biden's eight years as
vice president nearly two million
americans of prime working age had
dropped out of the workforce
our factories were stolen our country
was doing lousy
he lost nearly 200 000 manufacturing
jobs
he was by the way a disaster on
swine flu he got a horrible rating
in gallup look at the gallup
so they call it god h1n1 right
do you remember h1 swine flu h1n1
he calls it n1h1 but i don't hold them
in that one that's one of the small
mistakes
the bigger mistakes is when he says he's
in a different this can't be real right
i mean wake me up
in the great state of ohio but no no no
we're not in ohio
you know what you do you know what you
know what you do when that happens you
just walk off because there's nothing
you can do to recover
it's happened to him like what six times
almost every time
that's why he doesn't talk he's shot
he's shot we gotta say look one thing
i've learned
putin president xi of china right
kim jong-un erdogan of turkey
they are world-class chess players
we can't have a guy who's shot and it
his best years wasn't very good
he wasn't very good we can't have it
these guys are world-class
chess player
they're all dreaming they're all
dreaming of joe biden i'll tell you
who's dreaming about
him is iran if we win and when we win
we are going to have a deal with iran
immediately they're just waiting hoping
that biden gets in
why not make the deal now you're saying
oh he should he by the way
if anybody violated the logan act it was
john kerry right
john kerry not general flynn john kerry
the cost of health insurance for
american families had skyrocketed under
obama and biden by four thousand
eight hundred dollars and nearly 11
million more americans were in food
stamps so biden's
abysmal record but you do have to check
swine flu
because that was peanuts compared to
this month mania
is the worst thing that's happened in
this world
since 1917 right
where 1918 flew people died
swine flu though look at his ratings in
gallup
check them out they gave them really bad
ratings
joe bite nothing that matters but that
does matter right you know when a guy
is critical and we've done an incredible
job including
among the best numbers in the world joe
biden's abysmal record
of failure and betrayal ended it's
actually
i'm taking a step back because you it's
just about everything he's saying is
untrue like what's the point of even
trying to keep up with this insanity
it's garbage japan i told japan
prime minister abby great guy but i said
prime minister you have to build
places in michigan you have to build
your places in
other countries other other areas of our
country
it's not fair we have a big deficit go
to wisconsin
go to ohio go to these places
he said he's going to do it many many
japanese plants now are being built all
over our country
somebody had to ask him to do it
somebody had to tell them to do it
it's not fair and it was all happening
then it came in now it's going out
watch what's going to happen watch how
good the third quarter is
the third quarter is coming up right
it's a rorschach test he's just
throwing ink and it's just pooling and
it
i've never seen a speech this bad
but we passed massive tax cuts we passed
massive regulation cuts and you know
what you might not feel this
maybe the most important thing i did for
making the economy great
wasn't just the tax cuts it was the
regulation cuts
because the regulation cuts allowed
companies to go out and build projects
that they couldn't get approved for 15
years and 20 years
right this doesn't seem like a well
person aside from the political
material or or fact it's just it's an
unwell person
with the brand new usmca which puts us
right at the top
and now canada and mexico are doing
what's right for our country
[Music]
it's been a great deal and when the
wisconsin timber industry
was being threatened my administration
took immediate action
we impose tariffs on dumped foreign
goods
and subsidized products saving countless
timber jobs
all across your state and you know
exactly what i'm talking about
you were taken advantage of by stupid
u.s policy canada was taking
advantage of this country not anymore
okay
[Applause]
if biden and the crew get in the radical
left will bring
timber production to a total halt i
stood up to china's decades of trading
abuses
and when china targeted our farmers we
provided
28 billion dollars in relief we gave our
farmers
i said to secretary perdue secretary of
agriculture
sonny how much they've targeted our
farmers
how much have they been targeted for sir
two years ago it was twelve years last
year was 16 billion 28 billion total i
said
guess what we're charging tariffs of 28
billion dollars to china
we charge them much more and we gain
remember when we
tariff chinese stuff it's american
companies
importing the stuff that pay the tariffs
and
i'm exhausted having to repeat that all
the time i have
am i right we did a good job i'll tell
you what with a
more typical president i want to be nice
more typical
every farmer would be out of business
right now but we gave 28 billion to the
farmers
oh socialism oh okay the farmers are
doing well right
and then we signed a deal with china and
i was very excited because i had a very
good relationship with president xi we
signed a great deal
and they under the deal they would buy
240 billion dollars 50 billion of
farm product and then manufacturing once
the china
flu came in once the china stuff came in
i was not
really i wasn't i couldn't it was
different
but i have to tell you four days ago
the corn order right was the largest
corn order
in the history of ordering corn
yep corn is a huge thing yeah it was the
biggest
china order two days when will he point
to the crowd and say where is my
african-american that's what i'm waiting
for
look at soybeans it was the largest
soybean order
in history in history and also beef
cattle etc
so it just shows you how smart china is
we sign a deal
and the plague comes in it might have
been a mistake it might have been on
purpose who knows what happened
now he's floating that th this might be
a bio weapon
he says now it might have china might
have released it on purpose he now says
about coronavirus
it's not so smart in that position scott
would have said oh
we don't like the way he's talking about
us let's immediately
shut down he didn't do that they said
let's order more from the farmers that
we've ever ordered biggest corn biggest
soybean
biggest cattle and now i'm getting my
farmers saying sir
we're starting to like china i said you
know what
we got to be very careful you understand
that so what they've done is they've
gone out they've made
massive orders so think how smart that
is though
99 of people in that position would say
well we're not going to order anymore
imagine waiting around in the crowd for
hours for this
corraled uh and then trump shows up and
just rants about things you
you just don't even know what he's
talking about and you have to wait for
hours for this
from joe biden's 47 year worth of
disaster
you know it's incredible he's in there
for 47 years he does nothing
now all of a sudden he's going to do all
these things he's going to get tough on
china
sure china will own the united states
if we don't make this deal and we were
going up
if we don't get elected you could go and
survey the crowd and say
what deal did donald trump just refer to
by saying this deal
what percentage of the crowd do you
think would be able to answer what deal
trump just referred to what what number
would you put on it
they made with obama they got a 150
billion dollars
1.8 billion in cash green cash oh major
raid from stephen kenneth destiny
bennell ii i call him as i call him
kenny too
that's how i know i grew up knowing him
that way but a welcome to everybody
coming in from the very powerful destiny
stream glad you're here
that's for the evangelicals
you know what's amazing with that the
evangelicals are more excited
about that than jewish people it's
really uh-oh
right it's incredible dicey territory
and golan heights don't forget golan
heights we did go
on highs so we've done a lot we did it
in february biden said
if you elect me your taxes are going to
be raised
they're not going to be cut now that's a
quote how the hell do you do this
that only in this state can we get away
with it
can't anybody pull them off you're right
okay you happen to be right
so i just want to say this this has been
an incredible
experience for me getting to know you
i've been here a lot
he flew in for 90 minutes and toured a
factory
he's gotten to know you
it looks like security's kind of
shifting around this must be a signal
that he's doing the wind down
we've been great for each other it's
really you know it's a partnership in a
sense but we've been great for each
other we brought a lot of business to
the state
we're bringing a lot more business to
the state whether it's uh the ships or
the
crops or any one of so many different
things especially
what ships are going to wisconsin go
because because of wisconsin
and your specialized milk a small
subject
but the right farmers got me at the
right time and they said wow you guys
are really being taken
advantage of with canada charging you
287
tariff i bet i think you mostly know
about that but unless you were up here a
lot like i was
you'd never find that out and i worked
with scott and i worked with others and
we solved
by the way if you're just joining us
from the destiny channel and you're
wondering what that you
you're assuming you must have missed
something to understand what trump's
talking about
no we we have just as little of an idea
what he's talking about as you do max
we've got to win this election
okay we have many things to do
we want to finish it up it's no
different you plant a tree
it takes a little time to grab on in
addition we have other things we're
going to do
more regulation cutting has trump ever
used a metaphor before
very substantial tax cuts because that's
an incentive toward growth
and we're going to do it and we proved
to be right we proved to be a hundred
percent right
we're not letting them raise your taxes
on you and destroy everything that we've
done
so i just want to thank the incredible
people of wisconsin
you really are you really are you're a
state
that despite everything everything that
they were saying well wisconsin can't be
won
wisconsin guess what and i think we're
much
we're way far ahead i do believe we're
way far ahead
where we were if you look back four
years i think we have much more spirit
the spoke the polls don't say it's
easier in a sense
now the virus made it a little bit more
difficult maybe a lot more difficult
because all of a sudden something
happened that nobody ever even thought
about
but we handled it we handled it and we
handled it well and we're now helping
other countries with the ventilators
and other things but the easier part is
i used to come up
as a businessman i was very successful
and i'd say we're going to do this we're
going to do tax cuts we're going to
even space force i never even talked
about space force
we did more somebody said we actually
did more than we promised that's never
happened with a politician before
it's it and it certainly hasn't happened
this time i talked about space force
and then i got into office i said we
need that because you look at what china
has he told 250 lies during this what he
did
is where would you put the over under
like has he actually lied 250 times
during this speech i don't think it's an
unreasonable number to estimate
right but and you're a big beneficiary
easily right so we have to win the
election
we can't play games get out and vote
do those uh beautiful absentee ballots
or
just make sure your vote gets counted
make sure
because the only way we're going to lose
this election
is if the election is rigged to remember
that that's the only way we're going to
lose this
interesting so we have to be very
careful dangerous statement
look we have this is more than this
election that's a big statement
the only way they're going to win is
that way and we can't let that happen
and you know our post office we're going
to make our post office great it's been
a disaster by shutting it down we're
going to take care of the men and women
in the post office and we're going to
make it great
right now it's a laughing stock amazon
and these companies come in
they dop they drop all of their packages
into the post office
and the post office loses trillion i
mean just
hundreds of billions of dollars
delivering these people the post office
is
losing hundreds of billions and i don't
know if that passes the sniff test
but we're gonna make our post office
strong we're gonna make our post office
really strong and really great we're
going to be proud of it again
it lost 78 billion in a short period of
time
over the last 12 or 13 years
so it went from it loses trillions to
loses hundreds of billions to lost 78
billion
over 12 years which is really not that
much when you consider is really a
public service not a business
win and we will make america great again
that was amazing
oh wow ending very low energy
okay as they was that ymca starting to
crank we of course want to stop that
before i get hit with some copyright
claims
what an insane speech now i do want to
remind you guys 8
40 p.m tonight that's two and a half
hours from now
democratic convention coverage starts
right here on youtube twitch and
facebook video so don't miss it i want
i'm gonna be taking a break i'm gonna be
cleaning up i'll be showering i'll be
grilling i'm going to be doing all sorts
of things but then i'll be back at 8 40.
so we we will be back to oh my god what
is trump doing that was a weird dance
uh we will be back with the convention
tonight but
what a whacked out presentation there
from donald trump
as he is going to sort of wander off and
hopefully
towards the plane sometimes he wanders
in the wrong direction and somebody has
to kind of grab him and pull him back
uh in the right direction but very very
bizarre
stuff i think probably 400 lies he told
would be my estimate if i had to say
um but uh you know we'd have to get sort
of a more official count there
and also the placement of the camera
hides him during his entire
approach to and walk away from the
podium which is
unfortunate placement and there as you
can oh maybe it's meant to hide his
instability going down the staircase
that's interesting i don't know what
what the deal was with that
listen if you are heading out on youtube
please hit the subscribe button on the
way out
we are just moments from hitting 950 000
subscribers we're trying to get to a
million by election day
but we could get to 950 000. we're 400
away
we have 11 000 people watching think of
the math my friends
400 away 11 000 people watching so if
you're headed out please hit that
subscribe button you'll also be notified
in that case
of when i go live later here you see
trump
kaylee magananny um
i don't know what's going on it looks
like oh trump's doing that weird posture
where he's sort of hinged forward at the
waist
i've never seen anybody stand like that
it's very very weird
um and i don't know what
just very weird logistical issues
happening
of course i will also be streaming on
twitch later today so if you are heading
out on twitch make sure to follow my
channel
and you'll be notified when i go live in
just a couple of hours the first night
of the dnc we will be hearing i believe
tonight it's bernie sanders
and michelle obama that's on tap tonight
and we're going to be doing a lot of
things
let me as we watch trump here i promised
i would thank new members and i want to
stephen douglas is new member number
five on my website
miles greer is number six brian
taylor is number seven nicholas weiss
is new member number eight um
susan tucker is new member number nine
today i wanna make sure everybody gets
their
deserved thanks joanie mcgillick
is new member number 10 at
joinedpakman.com
steven rivera you are number 11. matthew
tilley is number 12.
mark davis is number 13.
where are we here almer gerbic
oh boy i'm having trouble with that one
number 14
katie martin you were new member number
15 leonard
cattenberg is number 16 is donald donald
trump continuing to stand in an unusual
way i've never seen anybody do before
and i think that that gets me caught up
on all new members there
um super chats exploded during this
thing
a few that i want to mention chris
burnecker says
and we in germany wonder why he isn't in
jail yet that's a great
that's a great question james montalbano
says david he says 1917 because
last year the movie 1917 came out
um i met steven robbins asking if i'm
taking calls tonight i don't know
hey by the way you guys want to help me
test the new call system real quick
uh if you go to slash davidpakman.com
right now it should redirect you to the
brand new
official david pakman show discord all
other discords are unofficial okay
let let me just test one call right now
if you guys want because we might use
this later davidpakman.com
slash discord how what am i so we have a
waiting lobby oh my god it's filling up
right now i see it all happening
i don't know how to bring someone on i
think if you go to the waiting lobby
let me see here and if i right click
someone
i don't know exactly how to do it um
would anybody know like how do i take
someone from the waiting lobby
and put them on if anybody can tell me
how to do that
uh i drag them okay we're gonna try it
okay i'm gonna try taking a call right
now
on on my discord which is of course
davidpak i'm sorry yeah davidpakman.com
discord i'm going to try just please
this is a
crazy moment let's see someone who has a
microphone enabled
um how about this is risky there's so
many people trying to get on
i'm gonna drag oh god it's all moving
too quick
i'm gonna drag ross okay ross i hope
you're ready
to the call room ross can you hear me
ross are you there
hmm
okay i'm in the call room
ross i'm in i seem to be in a call with
ross
let me check here all right we're
testing in real time my friends
it might be my settings let me look here
at my audio and
video um input device
okay hold on here's my input device
output device
okay ross can you hear me ross yes
you're there
yeah you sound like a robot but i can
hear you oh i sound like a robot okay
hold on
let's see i'm gonna choose a different
microphone i have any number of
microphones available
input device different microphone ross
house that sounds a lot better
oh my goodness ross you're on you're our
first discord caller the quality you are
pristine right now
oh i'm happy to be here what can i do
for you
uh i'm i'm from wisconsin and uh i just
think
wanted to know what you thought about
the uh his rally today oh
it's it's disgusting i mean it's uh you
know this is the stuff that
anthropologists in the future
are going to have to look at this and uh
analyze it and and say what on earth
happened in the united states it was
it's it maybe was the most manic and
unhinged that i've seen donald trump
hey can i ask you you used to do a lot
of content with destiny
and now it looks like he's good friends
with milo yiannopoulos are you and him
going to have another talk soon
stephen kenneth destiny bonnell is
friends with milo destiny yiannopoulos
ii
uh i don't know just milo yiannopoulos
oh i don't know about that other part
there must be two different people i had
i have no idea about anything going on
with stephen and milo
but i'm glad to have steven on anytime
and even tonight during the dnc stream
i'd be willing to have him on
well i'd i'll tune in yeah thanks for
bringing me in i appreciate it david all
right let them know let them know okay
that i'm looking to have them on
all right sounds good okay very good
okay disconnect and that ended the call
okay that wasn't bad right i mean rp
does that
how is the call quality there compared
to when i do phone lines can anybody
say
it's bad okay it's better
all right let's try one more uh we have
a new discord
which is davidpakman.com discord
let me try bringing in oh i don't know
oh you know what if this is if this is
raygun i'm gonna bring in raygun and see
what's going on
stephen are you with us
hmm let's see here
raygun
raygun can you hear me
hmm not so good all of a sudden
i dragged in raygun but i'm not really
i'm not i'm not hearing anything
ray gun is gone oh i see i see okay
let's try um oh wait a second no ray gun
is not gone what's going on here
oh wait raygun are you there now
ray gun
it's all it's all seems to be now i
don't think the issue is on my end
that's weird i'm in a call with ray gun
everything is selected beautifully
raygun maybe you're muted last
opportunity for ray gun otherwise we're
gonna have to probably abort
yeah all right didn't work maybe raygun
walked away
that's weird um
all right let's try i'll try one more
oh it does show ray gun was muted oh
that's interesting
let's try um
i'm gonna bring in tc brady okay we're
bringing in
tc brady here and tc brady it
shows that you're muted oh my god there
you are tc brady you can hear me
hello david hi oh
[Laughter]
hello
tc brady what can i do for you um
i don't know i just you had no plan did
you
um no no all right
all right tc brady listen it's a
technology test we're testing the
technology
um it doesn't mean we were gonna do so
listen it works guys and so
later for the dnc stream we may be able
to use that as a tool
okay all right i'm gonna go uh it's uh
almost dinner time and all of that i
gotta get ready for my stream later
on youtube please hit that subscribe
button get us to 950 000 subscribers
follow on twitch as well to be notified
later when the dnc
stream starts i guess i'll see everybody
in a couple of hours
thank you
you